Закарпаття...
Мальовничий, чарівний і такий рідний край для майже мільйона українців.
Цих мультиків взагалі є мінімум на Україні, тому що це роблять декілька людей,
І більшість — десь 90%, роблять це для комерції. Вони це малюють і надсилають в інші країни,
просто аніматори працюють на замовлення.
А для себе, просто так, що от, наприклад, я заплачу за це гроші, закину на Ютуб і отримаю перегляди, —
так не працює практично ніхто...
Крім нас! Була така ситуація, що нам треба було другого аніматора, бо ми не вкладались у терміни
Ми почали шукати, — нікого немає, є лише київські чуваки
Вони назвали нам ціну...
Ми дзвонимо йому, а він говорить:
"Без питань, я готовий взятись, 500 доларів коштує хвилина такої анімації"
Я йому кажу: "Ти розумієш, 500 доларів — це наш бюджет для двох серій,  взагалі на все,
Двох серій по 25 хвилин...". Ну, він посміявся, ми посміялися, і він кинув трубку.
Це Мукачево, дєтка!
Та ти знаєш, хто мій тато?
Ну побілку, звичайно, вже і замінити можна було...
Конкретної такої цілі, щоб ми от сіли і вирішили зробити перший закарпатський мультик, не було.
Був просто такий хаотичний "серфінг" в інтернеті, і я наптрапив на відеороботу чувака,
першокурсника медичного факультету, який собі на день першокурсника зробив такий
п'ятнадцяти чи тридцятисекундний ролик, де він намалював викладачів, медичний факультет наш...
Ми на той час займалися КВН, і цей період якраз для нас закінчувався,
і треба було щось далі, далі щось ще робити. Ми подумали, що прикольно було б мультики робити...
В нас на Закарпатті дуже багато моментів... Ми одразу позгадували ці всякі угорські паспорти,
контрабанду, наш діалект...
Вона мені каже, що я дурна
Я? І це після усього того...
О-о-о-о-о-о, Боже! Сакура!
Вітьку, сфотографуй , сфотографуй мене, бо у мене ще нема такої фотографії!
Сфотографував? Сфотографував?
Справа в тому, що цьому треба дійсно приділяти досить великий об'єм часу
У нас є наша основна діяльність — це організація і проведення різних святкових заходів,
і ми просто застрягаємо у цьому всьому впродовж року, і тільки коли десь
вимальовується якийсь тиждень-два, тоді ми можемо спокійно сісти і писати сценарій.
Коротше, робота над мильтиком продовжується, коли починається піст.
Так, коли піст, коли люди не святкують весілля, тоді ми просто сидимо, банально, і пишемо...
Ну і скільки коштує?
За цю кралю всього-на-всього  250 тисяч євро
Зрозумів! А готівку берете?
Звісно.
А не біда, якщо дрібними? В мене тут назбиралось...
Тут є 98 гривень, тут є 64...
Із ста, двохсот, трьохсот коментарів, які з'являються на Ютуб,
є якийсь певний відсоток людей, які пишуть: "О господи, ви обсміюєте..."
Не так, вони пишуть: "Господи, что это такое?"
Ні, ну є і ті, що російською пишуть. Цe люди, які не зовсім розуміють зміст цього всього,
тому я на це нормально реагую, але коли наші закарпатці пишуть про те,
що ми висміюємо Закарпаття, замість того, щоб розказати, як тут класно.
Ми вважаємо, що через призму гумору можна розказати,що ми круті, ми особливі,
ми відрізняємось від інших. Ми маємо три кордони, два паспорти, тунелі і тому подібні речі.
Чому про це не говорити?
Треба звертати увагу на деталі у мультику завжди, тому що це — прихований гумор.
Оцей чувак, який б'ється головою об землю, інший — грається кішкою.
Усі вони ідеально промальовані.
Ось, він просто б'ється головою об землю.
Бреде, я ніяк не можу вибрати...
Соккере, візьми мене, бо плюну!
У нас дуже часто питають, яка підтримка вам треба? Що вам потрібно від людей?
Нічого, просто, щоб дивилися, щоб їм подобалось.
Тобто, ми готові і далі свої фінанси в це вкладати, нам це на даний момент подобається,
Якби було трохи більше часу, ми би робили це якомога частіше.
Привіт, Ukraїner! Я — Сєрий. А я — Мікі, ми цей, коротше, ми із Закарпаття.
Так, так, із Закарпаття. Ми би вас хотіли привітати із святами, що наближаються
З якими? Різдво, Пасха, одразу наперед, не факт, що побачимось скоро.
І бажаємо вам щастя, здоровля
Якщо раптом щось, не плутайте — є здоров'я, а по-закарпатськи це — "здоровля"
І, ну, удачі!
Ну, і зрозуміло, на многая і благая літ!
Чуєш, Мікі, а як пісні переключати, не знаєш? Та хто зна, там, здається, диск уже поцарапався.
Що ти дивишся? Зараз, Мікі, якраз ця пісня має в титрах грати.